so when i came up with the idea for divi
was really based on a couple of things
personal experience and then
understanding the market from the market
side let's start with that
i saw that we had just made it out of
the global financial crisis
if you looked at the rates of
homeownership they were at all-time lows
and i thought
you know people can't get mortgages
there has to be another option that we
can offer them
and so wanted to figure out a way in
which people could buy into the equity
of homes
without taking on a massive amount of
risk from a credit lending perspective
and so making them into a renter letting
them buy
into the equities sharing in the
appreciation um seemed to
seem to be a good idea as a way to start
and then more on the personal side
my my parents myself i i couldn't get a
mortgage
my dad when he had immigrated to the us
couldn't get a mortgage um
him and my mom had actually just gotten
married just got pregnant and they were
looking for a house couldn't find one
um and and then ultimately they found a
lovely woman who was willing to give
them seller financing on a home and that
house
became my family's sole source of
savings and wealth and
eventually my dad had a credit score
refinance that house with a mortgage and
was able to take cash out and use that
to pay for
for me my three siblings to go to
college so from a personal perspective
yeah
yeah personal perspective i i get the
value of home ownership and then from a
business perspective i think the market
uh
was was pretty um in an interesting and
unique spot to actually disrupt it
great and so when did you start the
company and then how many homes uh have
been bought this way
so we founded it in 2017 and then
started purchasing homes in 2018.
we don't publicly publicly release how
many homes we we've purchased but i will
say there's dozens hundreds
thousands
wow thousands of homes now is there a
certain
uh value of homes and an ideal customer
profile here because
if i remember correctly you brought up
the great financial crisis which was in
fact
caused by people who maybe traditionally
shouldn't have had a home
buying a home and here you are saying
we're going to help people who
traditionally
wouldn't get a home and buy a home so
how is it different than what got us in
trouble last time
that's a great question well to your
first your first question is we we serve
16 markets we are not in san francisco
and new york i always joke we're not
solving for
uh the problems of of the coastal cities
and the bay
area folks but instead of america you're
not here today
madness we're solving the problem for
the rest of america so our markets are
dallas houston atlanta yes um
and our average home price today it
varies by market to some place like
dallas for maybe 350 000
home um someplace like cleveland will be
150 000 but it averages to call it
around 250 000
and in terms of your your your more
provocative question which i i very much
enjoy we actually when we first
fundraise
uh we got this question where someone
asked if we're the new subprime
which i think kind of got to your
question
so i mean i kind of know the answer but
i'm asking on behalf of the audience
yeah like yeah yes i understand so
so just to give you the audience a
little bit of context um for the 20
years before the global financial crisis
underwriting requirements were much
looser than they had been in previous
times that's why when you think your
parents got a starter home really easily
that's because they did
and it is much harder for you to get a
mortgage today than it was for them to
get one
20 years ago that obviously led to the
global financial crisis underwriting
tightened
and get became very restrictive after
that so the average fico that you needed
to actually
get a home went from somewhere on
average around 700 up to about a 740
fico
right so all of a sudden there's there's
a ton of people who maybe can't access
home ownership
now the difference between divi and what
had happened during the global financial
crisis is
during the global financial crisis you
were extended debt you were given credit
a mortgage
divvy is very different there is no debt
i'm not lending you anything
you are a pure renter in the home which
is what you would have been
if you weren't owning anyway right
you're an owner or your renter it's one
or the other so you're you're a renter
and you're not actually an owner
and you're just buying into the equity
of the property that is pure savings
that is not debt those savings are the
same way that you can save and put your
money into the s
p into a 401k into other things that
compound and appreciate over time
so the difference is we are not lending
to our consumers
and instead we are basically a for
savings mechanism
in an asset that appreciates and
compounds their wealth over time
and you're if i correct me if i'm wrong
here just to
bring up naseem tuleb you have the skin
in the game
you are buying these homes yourself so
you are on the hook for the home as
opposed to in the financial crisis where
you had these
uh financial instruments and sharky
you know low moral character
people signing up uh let's face it first
time
home buyers who maybe weren't as
educated as they needed to be in
starting with doc
and depending on what documents they
signed they didn't know what they were
signing and putting them into
instruments they should never have been
in
but they didn't care because they were
just getting the commission and they
were done
yes if you were to do something like
that you're the bag holder
yes we are fully the bag holder so we're
buying the homes the
the risk the assets are being purchased
fully by divi we have
we buy them with part equity and part
debt we are responsible ultimately for
that debt
the renter that we're putting into the
house is purely just a renter
that's building equity in a synthetic
equity account in a ledger
right um and so so we are the ultimate
owner of the house and we are on the
hook for all the homes that we do
purchase
all right so we had this scenario of the
350 thousand dollar home in dallas
30-year mortgage three percent apr
monthly payment would be 1264. uh 12.65
for that what do you charge people then
um
if they didn't have to put a down
payment down right they're not putting a
down payment down
you put the down payment down so then
what would the rent be on a house like
that
if we took this prototypical one that
you outlined so
i'm going to use easier numbers than
your 1264 and just say let's say on
average we're we're in an area where
rent is roughly a thousand dollars a
month
for a house where you're paying rent of
about a thousand dollars a month roughly
your mortgage payments let's say are
i don't know 700 a month or something
like that now
on top of that you need to pay like 150
k house i'm just guessing
yes exactly yeah and uh
i'd say more like 150 um but on top of
that 700 you'd have to pay maintenance
taxes and insurance right which a
landlord typically covers completely for
you
so let's say that 700 is now maybe 8.50
right 850 a month versus the thousand
dollars to rent the delta between that
is how much your landlord typically
makes right that is their
i mean they have to pay out right
interest and other things like that so
but there's some spread there right
so divi would charge you that a thousand
dollars a month but then on top of it we
add in a savings portion which might be
something like 250
a month so instead of paying a thousand
you're paying 12.50
but the equity portion is actually your
savings
that gets invested in the house and as
the house appreciates you own a
percentage of the house so your savings
also appreciates with the house
how much time and money do you spend
integrating a bunch of different
software products together
let me guess way too much well odoo is
here to help
odoo is a suite of business apps that
runs your entire company
on one platform they'll streamline your
workflow
to bring all that information together
plus odoo's integrations
eliminate repetitive tasks and data
entry
if you only need two or three apps to
optimize your workflow
that's all you're going to pay for odoo
won't stick you with the bill for apps
you don't use
and odoo has an app for every business
need they offer 30 main apps
that are updated regularly and over 16
000 apps
from their active open source community
you can keep your books tight
with their financial software you can
add their sales and crm apps to help
provide a clear and organized view
of how you're doing as a team and here's
your simple
call to action your first app is free
forever and right now odoo is
offering a thousand dollar credit on
your first implementation pack
that's not a joke one thousand dollars
off go to odoo.com
twist to check it out odo.com
twist